unicef denuncia la grave situación de
los niños en un cráneo el director de
programas de emergencia del organismo
perteneciente a las naciones unidas dio
a conocer la preocupante condición de
los infantes en el contexto de la
invasión rusa de verse en familia hay
7.5 millones de niños en un cráneo esa
es la población de niños en un cráneo y
hay 2.8 desplazados internos y 2
millones de refugiados así que son 48
millones por así decirlo más o menos por
supuesto esas cifras evolucionan cada
día por desgracia
las cifras de la unicef destacan como
una de las mayores crisis registradas de
hearst 40 es bastante increíble yo
sinceramente no recuerdo muchos lugares
donde hayamos tenido un desplazamiento
tan grande de niños en tan poco tiempo
ser señor frank según el funcionario los
niños ucranianos están entre los
principales perjudicados en medio de los
combates
manuel fountain hizo además un llamado
de atención a la protección de los
pequeños quienes pueden ser víctimas
también de la violencia de género y
sexual los niños están siendo asesinados
y heridos de esa fortuna a través de
esta guerra a un ritmo increíble la
oficina de derechos humanos de la onu ha
verificado unos 142 niños asesinados y
alrededor de 230 heridos estos son los
números verificados pero sabemos que
ciertamente son mucho más altos
desafortunadamente en su más reciente
intervención ante el parlamento
surcoreano el presidente es selenski
denunció que unos novecientos treinta y
ocho centros educativos han sido
destruidos así como 300 hospitales